alright so the first problem here is to
prove that the roots of a polynomial in
the complex plane depend continuously on
the coefficients very true so maybe some
of you just know the proof from before
some suggestions from those who came up
with something right now anybody have a
suggestion how we might I know two
different ways to prove it one is
completely elementary and one uses
something about integration in the
complex plane
[Music]
like to come up here or yeah so we have
to use the definition at some point yeah
do it together on the board
so you're saying there's an elementary
proof which doesn't use anything okay
yeah yeah that's that's nice
because I think this proof is not widely
known and I mean you can do it yeah you
can
you have an n-tuple of fruits right I
guess maybe we have to be a little bit
careful so they're claiming that yeah
each you can somehow identify and label
the roots and each of them moves
continuously the tricky if you you might
have multiple roots but I guess it's
safe it's safe to say that if you know
ultra positive is that there's a root of
of this polynomial then we have a
sequence of polynomials that coefficient
wise converge to that and in that
sequence we can choose maybe subsequence
such that they don't have any root in
the vicinity of some particular root of
that of P yeah so let's yeah that should
be our starting
okay
the phenomenon itself is kinda used and
the fact that this polynomial means that
X bar is at peace so much is going to be
using something interesting that I'm
using so yeah but is it what exactly is
this statement yes
Oh
a second so so why I are their roots
they depend on epsilon you know yes but
I know that collagen are very important
[Applause]
no mystery underneath it because why did
you get this
[Music]
yes yeah I think I'm okay
did everybody follow a little bit
differently yeah yeah
so the fact about polynomials that you
use is that if the roots are at least
some distance from point O me then the
value you add those roots is at least
something and therefore in the limit it
cannot be zero this Delta does not
depend the author doesn't depend on
epsilon that's the interesting Sharon
and Nikhil the jewelry is jury satisfied
yeah
all right let me let me you can you
should make a case you should make this
circle small enough is that your point
that even the other roots the roots are
somewhere far away
he's evaluating at a point X for every
day there is and then that is
if you have an objection then you have
this saying that okay yes do you want to
actually the textbook the textbook proof
that probably people know is using a
contour
right so then the number of right so
then that's convenience inside
so if that's continuous the integrals
are like so the number versus month
listed stays inside as its inside it's
any country
yeah yeah it's yeah yeah thank you very
much okay everybody happy or does
anybody have a different proof very
basic fact but we all forgot these
things so the second second exercise is
about the Hermit Silvestre theorem so
we have this matrix
polynomial
hums okay all this matrix H I J we put
our some power some for a plus J minus
IJ between one and M so now we should
prove something about H being positive
semi-definite so let's first let me do
that for you because it's obvious what
you should do first let's look at what
this expression actually means X
transpose H X
no I mean One Direction is easy I think
one direction is a little bit if you
have an obvious solution for both
directions I'll be happy to you have to
do something I think in one direction
yeah yeah if it's not really rooted then
you have to show that this can be
negative one direction is pretty clear
so I'm not going to force anybody to go
to the board for that let me so what is
this expression
XJ so this is a summation of the roots
the power of a plus J minus 2 for the
summation X L
yeah so this is the quadratic form so
one direction is really easy because if
the roof if the roots are real then
they're for x-ray or oh this is
something squared something real squared
so it's certainly no negative that's
what I meant by the easy
so the other direction was not
completely obvious to me at first if you
have a polynomial which is not real
rooted how do you find a vector X such
that this is negative
so let me write this I'm not doing
anything I will not do anything
non-trivial
for you I will just some polynomial
let's call it u U is some polynomial
whose coefficients we can design
J lambda to the J one thing about Q is
that I'm only allowed to use degree and
minus one actually because this is an N
by n matrix and the powers only go up to
n minus one to be a little bit careful
about degree question is over eyes the
question given P X
so you make a zero except into complex
conjugant yeah so the roots are yeah I
should say maybe I didn't say that but
we assumed that the polynomial has real
coefficients okay
so complex roots form complex conjugate
pairs
right so there are n minus two routes
where you make it zero nasty yeah that's
how I would do it yeah actually I don't
know if I couldn't Google I couldn't
find it through slides yes so that's a
different way
okay so I'll let you do that next if you
want let's finish this are you man
because yeah that might be nice so yeah
so Sascha is suggesting I think what
what my intended solution was which is
basically use the roots of P so assume
the roots are so there's some complex
conjugate pair lambda let's say lambda 1
lambda 1 don't you get and then some
other stuff oh is lambda 3 and so on
so we form polynomial Q U of Z is the
product over all these other roots right
we should be careful if the same
conjugate pair appears multiple times
but let's ignore that I think it's not
it's not an issue but the formula so so
we take his product I think you can do
it directly but yeah let's let's ignore
that so so we have this and then we have
to add some stuff here which what we
call it a is Z a Z plus B
which basically is designed to move this
conjugate pair to plus minus I so we can
find choose a can everybody see that
choose a be real such that a lambda one
plus B is poss-eye
a lambda how'd you get was B is minus
either you can do that in the complex
plane we have some complex conjugate
pair so just map it to plus minus I find
linear function just scale it so that
you get there the imaginary component is
plus minus 1 and then then make the real
component 0 so we can do that right now
if you plug in any of these roots
starting from lambda 3 if you plug in
anything into Q you get 0 because this
will disappear
so for any L starting from from 3q
related lambda L is 0
clearly that product and you lambda
actually sorry so I wanted to design
this to be the value of the polynomial
to be which I can also do the value of Q
evaluated at lambda 1 or lambda 1
conjugate should be plus minus I plug in
lambda 1 or lambda 1 conjugate into this
I get some again some complex conjugates
pair so I can adjust the coefficients
here to make the value plus minus I does
everybody believe that some conjugates
pair so I can
this is some non-trivial complex
conjugate pair so I can scale it I can
move them along some line to hit the
imaginary axis somewhere I choose this
linear function so that it becomes plus
minus something imaginary then I just
scale is to make it boss - I
supposed to be an interactive session do
you agree or not there's an easier way
to say it yeah
[Music]
a complex conjugate pair you know I
apply them by zebra 4z I plug in lambda
1 lambda 1 conjugate this is some
non-trivial complex conjugate there so I
will get these two points and some other
complex conjugates there in the plane
it's not just the only thing I need
about these two pairs that they are not
just a real I have to let's call them
non-trivial non-trivial pair of complex
conjugate pairs so then I can combine
them by a linear combination somehow to
get a pure imaginary I don't want to
shift the polynomial because when I plug
in the other the roots it should be zero
so I don't want to just shift the
polynomial I want to multiply by
something I claim I can multiply it by a
linear factor with real coefficients
such that I cancel out the real part
after plugging in lambda 1 and I get the
pure imaginary pair plus minus Phi yeah
yeah I agree
Sasha agrees and that's it so yeah so I
have the property that Q of lambda 1
equals minus Q of lambda 1 ok this is
this plus minus I so I this quadratic
form where data if I plug in any root
except for the first pair I get 0 so
this is all 0 except plus I squared plus
minus I squared so it's actually - - so
I produce the vector which gives me
minus - I don't know that's my solution
and there's apparently another solution
which if you want same as using
something about positive semi definite
matrices rather than polynomials so
maybe if you like if you like you can
maybe we're just saying that two-factor
ages but about part of everyone that the
quadratic form is literally I don't know
I would still like to see it if you want
to write it down five minutes
take the polymer matrix 1 lambda square
so this says here up to indices that H
is B transpose B multiply it out you get
exactly the commitment tricks if you
multiply this one among matrices but now
you can simply diagonal the writing form
which is essentially written here it's a
sum of squares of linear forms the
question is what is sort of the
signature of this matrix so if the root
is real that we have a real square so
that thinks we want to die agonize over
it but if you have a complex conjugate
pair then or complex roots then this is
a complex linear formula consonance but
it's complex conjugate will show up also
so the thing you have to think about is
what happens if you add this linear form
is where
but let me do it put to take this thing
you're poor so this is take take a
complex number alpha suppose it's one of
the rows of my matrix multiply
and that is sort of multiply operation
so the real part squared and by that I
mean take real part coefficient one and
I'm missing something
imaginary parts so this is a sort of
diagonalized of the Reno's these are now
really near forums and thus have a
positive eigenvalue and the negative
Anakin so for every complex conjugate
pair of roots you actually get a
positive and the negative eigenvalue be
even more precise the signature of the
commitment recurrence the number of
fields and of its PSD then all of the
eigenvalues are negative so you counted
to only have billions you can even count
the number you have complex roots the
number of real roots complex will
disappear in the signature because they
continued a positive and a negative
any questions
thank you
all right so I guess we should if there
are no other call 50 we're supposed all
right good
[Applause]